hello everyone and welcome to today's
webinar proper controls for the bigfoot
spectral cytometer beads are not cells
but are they close
i'm susie valdez of labyrinths and i
will be your moderator for today's event
today's educational web seminar is
presented by lab roots and brought to
you by thermo fisher scientific to learn
more visit them at thermofisher.com
now we encourage you to participate
today by submitting any questions you
might have during the presentation to do
so simply type them into the ask a
question box and click send we'll answer
as many questions as we have time for at
the end of the presentation
you may also submit any technical issues
here as well if you have any trouble
seeing or hearing this presentation
this webinar is educational and thus
offers free continuing education credits
please click on the continuing education
window at the bottom of your screen to
obtain those credits i'd now like to
welcome our speaker david adams managing
director at university of michigan
biomedical research corps facilities in
flow cytometry core
david welcome you may now begin your
presentation sir
well thank you uh good morning everyone
um as she said my name is dave adams and
i've been running the university of
michigan flow core for the last 20 years
uh more importantly i like to start each
and every talk with a blatant typo
to set the audience at ease so for those
of you wondering about uh bigfoot
spectral
e
you're welcome
uh now thermo fisher is hosting this
webinar and the bigfoot is a remarkable
sorter but i'm going to try and keep my
con comments more system agnostic
each system excels in certain areas um
the bigfoot with its simplified workflow
the aurora with its exceptional ability
to handle universal negatives
the id7000 with its frustrating tendency
to be something i haven't bought yet
but in the end the approach to its
controls is similar across all systems
next slide button is
there the struggle to have users prepare
proper controls is certainly nothing new
um i asked a few core directors about
their biggest pet peeves
um when it comes to users and
compensation controls and the responses
were all eerily similar
and very much the same as my own i'm
sure if you uh take a glance at some of
these
you're all going to recognize uh some
issues that you've had to deal with
and with spectral these things really
only become more challenging
of course this challenge is at least to
some extent
a self-inflicted wound
in many cases our enthusiasm for the new
technology caused this to pass long
vendor claims
and as a result to set our user
expectations way too high
we've all heard and many of us have
repeated the idea that with spectral you
will no longer have to do compensation
um
that is of course blatantly untrue uh is
sure we're no longer telling the
instrument to take x percent out of uh
detector a
um
and
subtract it from detector b but we're
still compensating for spectral overlap
it's simply that by looking at the
fingerprint of each floor chrome
over a wide spectrum of both excitation
and emission we're no longer looking to
adjust the signal by a wee skoge and are
performing the spectral deconvolution in
in an information rich manner pulling
specific threads from the cellular
tapestry rather than uh scooping out
roughly the right amount of mint
chocolate chip from each signal
so
if we are still
quote unquote um
compensating
what is the difference in the necessary
controls between the conventional
compensation approach and spectral on
mixing
well honestly when you get down to it
there is no difference
in fact you know the dirty little secret
of spectral cytometry is that the
algorithm is actually even more
dependent on the same rules we've had
along
the algorithm requires proper controls
and allows for no shortcuts
i was speaking with rachel sheridan from
the van handles and i really think she
put it best when she said and i'm
paraphrasing here a bit
i like the spectral workflow because it
calls shenanigans on sloppy work much
sooner than conventional
so
if that's all true what are the proper
compensation controls
if you do a quick google search
you'll see spread across
unteen sites
these three simple rules of compensation
um that we just keep repeating
this is the university of iowa's uh
version and they're mostly true um going
in reverse order
um you have to have the same
fluorochrome for comp controls as used
in this example simple enough apc
shouldn't be used
to comp for our alexa floor 647.
um
with our gray matter historically
our wetware algorithm we've been able to
make that adjustment for the user
but in spectral it's not an option the
curve for apc is going to be very
different from alexa 4647 and you won't
be able to
make that adjustment
second uh background fluorescence should
be the same for the positive and the
negative
um
certainly this uh
makes sense when we're running beads we
need to have a negative uh bead sample
to cut to adjust against when running
cells we need to have
um
that
unstained cellular
sample present to compensate again
and i actually
um have started asking not only with
these i've asked my users to start
spiking in unstained uh cells with their
single positive controls because again
as i mentioned earlier um
not all systems
deal as well with the idea of a
universal negative and making sure that
we have unstained cells in every single
positive control
allows us to be sure that we're going to
get a a good clean spectral and mixing
every time
finally we come to this idea that the
controls need to be bright
or is brighter than any sample
any signal in the
experimental sample um pardon me
um
in spectral
this technically is no longer true
um
regardless of intensity
the curve for a given fluorochrome
is going to
look the same wherever it falls on scale
assuming that it is in fact contained
within the scale
however
i generally will intentionally fail to
mention this to my users
um because if they've made a mistake in
some other part of their control
then i know by having that brightest
sample is the single positive control
sample i'm still set up for success
should i have to revert from spectral to
a conventional compensation
procedure
now these rules are great
like i said we see them all over the
internet throughout course
because they're they're accurate they
served us well
but
when training our users for spectral
we really need to be more specific in
what we're telling them
as such we need to expand our list from
the three simple rules
to to something a bit more elaborate and
first we have to be absolutely certain
absolutely certain that users understand
that the negative controls
and the viability controls must be cells
this is necessary to account for
autofluorescence and the inability of
spectral workflow to to account for fake
viability markers
in my conversations with other core
directors i had one individual state
that their users insist on bringing
beads with ecd on them to act as a
viability control for the pi state
again our wet wear matrix can make those
adjustments we can make that system work
but the spectral algorithm
simply will not allow
this
on mixing to proceed because the curves
are different
um
control samples
should be treated
identically
to the stain samples
now i found my own users failing to
follow this rule actually i had a
vendor's tax specialist point out that
some of my users weren't following this
rule which is infinitely worse
um but controls and experimental samples
need to be treated the same way the
buffers used matter the washes matter
fixation status matters
these all affect the nature of the final
products short tips here can schedule
your experiment
one of uh
spectral's early promises
was the idea that
a reference library could be created
so that under appropriate circumstances
and i'm going to highlight that phrase
under appropriate circumstances the
library could be used instead of
preparing single positive controls
now this is actually a practice i
actively discourage in my lab as i want
my users to prepare complete experiments
each time call me superstitious
um but it is important that users
understand
that this library concept does not apply
to tandems dot tandem dies
tandems age they leak they dissociate
over time p psi 7 is the poster child of
bad tandem behavior and users need to
know that these curves can and they will
change with each use
and i hit the next slide and did not
move to the next one please hold
technical difficulty
um
kanji gets used uh
for the control and experimental samples
really need to be from the same latin
company
while the fluorochromes produced by acme
and those produced by aperture science
are all going to
be detected through the same bandpass
filters on our instrument
that doesn't mean that the spectral
curves are going to be identical
age and manufacturing process affect the
final product
but so far
all of these rules have been fairly easy
to follow
good practices
will yield good results
but what about situations where things
aren't so simple
what about situations where
they've got a dim marker
and you can't fully resolve it from the
negative control
well
even even with the spectral algorithm
you've got to assign positivity and
negativity and with a dim marker
it's hard to do it makes for a poor comp
control
rare populations make for poor comp
controls if the population is
sufficiently rare you may never get
enough events for a positive peak
that the algorithm can act on
and if they're using fluorescent
proteins
even though we have to ask our users
time and time again
to make sure that these proteins don't
fall into single positive controls for
other colors
invariably we end up seeing them
so
what do we do in this situation um where
do we go well we need another solution
and
that solution
is a compensation beat
now i promise to be agnostic
but i am going to state that ultracomp
and ultracomp plus beads
are simply the best beads for the job
they are more compatible over a wider
range of experimental workflows than
their competitors
um the author would like to state that
um
he is a no way acting
paid sponsor but ultracomp beads for the
win
so
using compensation beads it is a simple
enough procedure
but the same care has to be utilized
when prepping bead samples of cellular
samples
and there is an excellent resource out
there
currently available for everyone to read
it's free access
and it's in the september issue of
current protocols
and in fact i'm going to be stealing
heavily
from
the article in the next few slides um if
you take a look at the
authors listed on the article i'm sure
you will be able to
recognize the expertise this president
grab that article
read that article go into your lab and
frame that article um
everything in there is so very important
to optimizing that spectral experiment
so uh make uh it's free access so make
copies pass it around to all your users
it's long
because it covers a lot of different
what-ifs but it is well worth your time
so
assessment
of your experiment uh starts with uh
determining uh
where things are appropriate used
cellular controls here speed controls
there
and
they have described and a lot of us have
come to the realization on our own
that the easiest way to determine
whether beads
make for a successful control set
is to
actually throw them on the cytometer and
find gaps
and
in order to do this
you really have to again set yourself up
for success so the first step
is always going to be to titrate your
antibodies
this step for whatever reason
is one of the first to be skipped by
users in their experimental designs
and yet it's clearly the most critical
in order to ensure that you have enough
stain to properly resolve a population
and yet not so much stain as to obscure
the signal with induced noise
so the users have to titrate their
reagents every time
they shouldn't use shortcuts like just
looking for the brightest staining point
they need to take the time to consider
the actual stating index
brightness and the spread of noise
most third-party software will calculate
these automatically for the users
so there's really no excuse for sloppy
technique
and as the person in charge of flow in
charge of the core
in charge of the stray instrument in
your lab
you really have to stand firm on this
titrate your antibodies
then
the next step then will be
for users to stay in their beads
and at this point i really want to call
you back to a previous slide
control samples should be treated
identically this
includes
beads
if you're staining your samples one way
you absolutely have to stain your beads
the same way they have to be washed just
like the cells the buffers matter
make sure that the cellular workflow
mirrors the bead workflow and you'll
reduce uh
problems experienced by the user
so
how do we proceed next
easy enough
you've got your experiment prepared
you run your negative negative and
viability controls
and then for every other control you use
b
once the bead controls are run
you do an unmixing
then
you take another set of controls
prepared with cells all the way across
the board and you run those sales
cellular
controls and unmixed samples
and at this
point although the matrix can get really
large um
if you're running a 20 color sample you
need to look at every color combination
and determine if the mixing produced no
errors
as in the first sample on the left or if
in fact the spectral on mixing is
sub-optimal
as in the sample on the right
and if
the sample is not appropriate or the
beads are not appropriate you're not
getting an appropriate mixing
then you need to
consider
something else for controls now that's
something else
maybe committing even more of that
excuse me for some reason my alexa has
started going off
uh that's something you generally don't
get in my office i apologize
um
so that's what i was saying um at that
point where you can see with the beads
you're getting an insufficient spectral
on mixing you either commit more of your
precious sample for controls
or
you need to identify a surrogate tissue
that tissue may be
another mouse sample with similar
protein
chemistry
uh
a similar cell line what have you but in
this case you're still going to have to
go through the procedure
titrating
you've done the titration so you then
need to
go through the control samples again now
using the surrogate tissue
unmix and then again look at your
samples
have them mixed properly
have they not unmixed properly
this uh i i do have a tendency to charge
through um
when i'm talking so this 30 minute
presentation has somehow ended up being
a 20 minute presentation
i apologize for that um
but i do want to thank you
uh for taking the time to consider
ways your users can optimize their
experiment
and um
i want to give special thanks
to the people at uh thermo fisher who
got me set up with my two bigfoots in a
timely manner and then special thanks
goes out to uh
rachel sheraton from the van andel and
jessica back from the uh
um caramano um
who uh i routinely used to bounce
thoughts and ideas off
and uh extra special thanks goes out to
my own flow state helmetry team here at
the university who as you can plainly
see we have never taken a group picture
together so
you can always reach out
to me
at the university if you have any
questions
but because of my tendency to talk very
very fast uh we do have time to actually
have a discussion so if anyone out there
has questions um wants to call uh
call me up for uh something i said that
they believe is wrong now would be a
good time to have that discussion
well thank you
for that wonderful
informative presentation and we will in
fact start the live q a portion
of this webinar if you have any
questions you want to ask dave please do
so now just click on that ask a question
box located on the far left of your
screen and we'll answer as many
questions as we have time for
so let's take a look we already have
some great questions from our audience
members coming in
dave you failed to mention fmo controls
can you share your thoughts on those
i absolutely can you are correct i did
not mention fmos
i i consider
in my own mind fmos fall into a
different category
it's not
they're not really involved in that
spectral unmixing um or the conventional
uh compensation workflow they're
actually an experimental control that
comes after that
and
if there's any doubt
um even
though
the spectral workflow produces
if done properly a superior on mixing
that still doesn't
remove
the
spectral background that's created by
having
10 15 20 25 30 different park rooms
emitting off these cells um the
background is oh there's always going to
be a higher spectral background on your
fully stained sample
than there is on the unstained cells and
as such i consider fmos to be critical
absolutely critical uh to the workflow
as your experiments become more and more
information and data rich
thank you so much our next audience
member asks what do you suggest in
situations where beads are not
appropriate but no surrogate tissue is
available how would you proceed
um well as i said
um
you can always commit more of the
original sample
but there's a lot of uh situations where
there's just not a lot of original
sample uh we do a lot of work with uh
drosophila brains and that sort of thing
and there's just
not much there so you can't really
commit that extra sample
so
you can get close with your uh
bead controls
and it's at that point
where if you don't have a surrogate
tissue you can use the beads just aren't
quite there
it's time to take a step back take a
deep breath
and remember that the machine doesn't
need spectral and mixing to function
um we the user needs spectral and mixing
in order to be able to draw those
populations
so it's time to sit down and really
evaluate your data and at this point
it's important to understand the biology
what it is you go into these experiments
you need you need to have some idea of
what you expect to see
so
you can even if the unmixing
isn't
absolutely correct
you can
take a look and see if the populations
you expect to see are still there and if
you can isolate them to get phenotypic
information if you can uh
draw gates to sort the populations out
maybe you're okay
um
if if not if things still look a little
cramped you can fall back on your gray
wear algorithm there's nothing
preventing you from taking an unmixed
sample
and tweaking
compensation in a conventional manner
however
if you make those choices
you need to disclose that information to
anybody you present the data to
and
it behooves you to verify that the
decisions you're making are appropriate
and these days um with the availability
of the technology
sequencing is a wonderful way to say you
know i had i had to tweak
the optics a bit i believe
that i i have identified or segregated
this population
well we're going to take one of these
flies and we're going to pass it on the
sequencing and make sure that what we're
saying
is the population
is actually the population
that we're giving people
thank you so much dave and again i want
to thank our audience for these great
questions coming in
our next question when you're
calculating your antibodies what pmt
voltage do you use and do you change the
this protocol
for spectral versus conventional flows
well that's a dangerous question
especially in the conventional end of
things
there are
there's always the argument new flow
versus old flow um in the conventional
workflow where you're you know overflow
you're setting your negative population
in that first decade
new flow where you're doing alterations
on your um instruments and setting those
voltages
to the
the optimum signal to noise ratio um on
the spectral side uh the machines try
and take care of that for you
um on the bigfoot you throw in your
negative sample and you uh
tell the machine what percent of scale
do i want my negatives falling you're
following it it's it's a bit of a
bit of a reflection of old flow there uh
but it does make sure you have a nice
even base uh to start your curve
on the aurora side of things on the
other hand they have their
qc process with their uh
scitec assay setting
um
where they're always trying to start the
machine again at that best signal the
noise ratio point um and you proceed
from there now where on both of these
machines that can be a challenge
is if you put on your controls and you
find that something's falling off scale
how do you adjust for that um well on
the bigfoot you uh might go back to your
negative control and say you set the
baseline at 25
maybe you set it for 26 to make sure
that the positives are captured on scale
but also just importantly that your
negatives aren't falling off scale um
on the on the aurora side with their
scitec settings it's important
because everything you do on that
machine uh relates back to the the
curves generated during those high-tech
assay settings
it's important that you um
first you're gusting lasers not
individual detectors
and if you lower or raise
the
laser power on one line that you
proportionally adjust all the uh other
lines
to make sure that the curves are still
proportional to what was developed in
the
scitec assay settings and um
again you need to ensure that if you're
lowering lowering laser power to make
sure that something stays on scale you
need to check and make sure that your
negatives are not being forced off scale
thank you so much
now are there ever cases where you need
to change your compensation controls
when transitioning a regular flow panel
to a spectral flow cytometer
um
yes
well
part of the uh
message i hope of this whole talk was if
you've done the job properly
conventionally
then
you don't have to change anything for a
spectral workflow
if all of your
if all of your controls follow all of
the rules you're good to go but again
there are situations where people have
been are relying on wet wear assumptions
i'll refer you back to that ecd for pi
um
and
you know dim populations that you get a
machine
algorithm isn't going to you you're not
going to be able to separate negative
from positive that again with our with
our brains we're able to make
assumptions we've seen it a thousand
times before we know how to tweak things
uh but in an ideal situation your
compensation control if they're prepared
properly for conventional they're going
to be prepared properly for a spectral
thank you so much now
can you still do manual compensation
with spectral flow cytometry
well as i mentioned
um
in situations where
the beads don't work a hundred percent
you don't have the um
a surrogate tissue that's appropriate
um
sometimes you have to to tweak it a
little bit uh using a more conventional
compensation but again if you do so it's
incumbent on you to not only disclose
that information
but to
prove
to the user prove to anyone they're
presenting to
that you know those assumptions resulted
in the tissue
um
that uh you say you say you're giving
the analysis you say you're giving is
correct and like i said there are ways
to do that sequencing and whatnot but
um once you add conventional to spectral
the burden is on you to prove that
that's an exceptional choice acceptable
choice
dave i want to thank you for your
presentation would you like to provide
any closing remarks to our audience
before we go
um i like cheese
sorry private jokes about three people
in the audience got that um
the rules
haven't changed
it's just with the spectral we need to
enforce the rules
and people have over decades develop
shortcuts um especially if they're
running the same procedure all the time
they try and operate in in
automatic mode and
any shortcut you take
is going to cost you in spectral
so
in theory it's a simplified workflow
but
le to get that simplified workflow you
have to be very precise in the
preparation before coming to the machine
and just
if you try and cut a corner you're going
to cut cut the
validity of your experiment
now
if um
like i said if you have any other
questions uh that occurred to you later
or want to chastise me for speaking so
fast um here's my contact information i
love it when people reach out and we can
have a discussion so make it so
i want to thank you again for your time
and for your presentation and i also
want to thank lab roots and our sponsor
thermo fisher scientific for
underwriting today's
educational webcast and before we go i
also want to thank our audience for
joining us today and for their
interesting questions questions we did
not have time for today and those
submitted during the on-demand period
will be addressed by our speaker via the
contact information you provided at the
time of registration
and this webcast can be viewed on demand
elaborates will alert you via email when
it's available for replay we encourage
you to share that email with your
colleagues who may have missed today's
live event until next time take care
everyone stay safe bye